(suspicious music)
(Patricia yells)
Oh, my goodness.
Oh my God, I can't believe this.
Holy cow, Patricia Bird, you are so beautiful.
I do, you're here, oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
(upbeat music)
You came for me?
I came for you, Patricia Bird.
We know your story.
We fell in love with you.
Oh.
And we wanted to come meet you and celebrate you
and tell you how much you inspire us.
Now, if you don't mind.
I don't.
Can I walk you outside
really quickly?
I can't believe this,
you are here.
(crowd cheering)
Oh my goodness!
They love me.
Oh, I'm loved.
We love you.
I can't believe she's here.
Get y'all, oh.
This is so wonderful.
It's your Drew Barrymore coming to Texas
to get you all in my presence.
I've not seen y'all in 10 years.
This is my Lawrence.
And you, did you meet Lauren?
I certainly did.
That's my Missy.
What's it like to have a mom
that you're so proud of?
That's like a rock star?
Yeah.
Just watching her, like just shine her light
amongst all of these kids and fellow, her colleagues.
It's just been amazing.
How do you tell yourself that you can do all the things
that you want to do and take care of everybody else?
It's called grace.
If you don't extend it to yourself,
you won't get it from anywhere else.
Not an easy road to travel
especially when you are type A personality.
What's something we can tell ourselves to go out there
and be bigger, better, stronger people?
Begin the day in quiet contemplation.
Decide what it is that you want to accomplish
within the 24 hours that are granted you
and work hard to check the list off
and for everything else that just give yourself grace,
those things that you did not accomplish,
draw that arrow to the next day
and tackle it the next day.
I feel like,
I wanna change my life starting tomorrow morning
in honor of you,
Good, good, Drew.
Patricia Bird, and live the rest of my life
to your standards.
And you do, you have so much to teach us.
And I'm so lucky to be a beneficiary of your wisdom
because I am just one of so many that feel that way.
(inspirational music)
Oh, wonderful.
(crowd applauding)
Drew Barrymore hugged me!
Oh my God!
I never would've expected in a million years.
I might even call it Bird time,
I don't know.
(crowd cheering)
And I was just so excited to also meet your community.
For all the things for which you would applaud me,
we've got to celebrate them too
because they've influenced who I am.
So can I clap?
Can I clap for them?
(Patricia clapping)
Thank you, Reggie.
Thank y'all so much, Missy
By the way, I have a sign too.
(crowd cheering)
Oh wow!
Did y'all see that? Yeah!
(crowd cheering)
Oh, that's awesome!
Ooh! Wonderful!
Tractor Supply is the largest
for all lifestyle retailer and is passionate about ensuring
that all kids have a safe place to play and grow
which is why they wanna give Plummer Elementary $20,000
to rebuild a state of the art playground.
(crowd cheering)
Oh my goodness.
Look! A playground for Plummer!
(crowd cheering)
Is it true that you're a fan of Chip and Joanna?
Oh my, oh, they're,
in my head they're my best friends, we're friends.
Do you wanna come to Waco with me to meet them?
Yeah!
(crowd clapping)
Yes!
(Drew laughing)
I'm going to share time with Chip and Joanna.
We're gonna go to Waco and see Chip and Jo,
but in the meantime, do you mind if I send you
and Lawrence on a vacation?
We are gonna send you and Lawrence
to the Playa Largo Resort in Florida.
(crowd cheering)
Yes! Yes, see!
A five night luxurious getaway
at Playa Largo Resort and Spa in the beautiful Florida Keys.
I'm a better person for meeting you.
Everyone's a better person for meeting you.
It is such a pleasure to meet all of you guys.
Thank you for letting me be a part of this moment.
(crowd cheering)
(inspirational music)